hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to berry now we're
beginning chapter 5 and we're almost
done with this again to recap chapter 4
was nuts it was basically running from
start to finish but now we're going to
figure out exactly what the consequences
of my actions are and why all of this
stuff is here we're now inside a large
reinforced chamber of sorts almost like
the inside of a submarine near us is the
door shut tight far away from us along
the back wall are all sorts of controls
and monitors it's in clear that this
metal door is impenetrable at least to
them I'm fairly sure that they aren't
getting in and it looks like a walking
course and I do everything in my power
to not let this show in my expression
his face was a grimace he shouts at me
to hell with you what were you thinking
blood pools on the floor below wherever
he holds his arm I say nothing it's all
too much my brain feels like jelly we
need to get him help or he's going to
bleed to death
Amy says we're interrupted by a man
voice booming behind us just what in the
hell do you think you're doing the man
roars is an older man who seems to exude
power and authority but he also looks
tired and scared
I assume this is Barksdale he walks over
to us from the back recesses of the
chamber we didn't have a choice Amy
responds we had to did you override the
locks on the hangar door yes I did but
we had to do you have any idea what you
could have done Amy doesn't answer right
away she's furious but she's also scared
and visibly quiet and exhausted I'm
gonna ask who this is who is this I
address my question to amy preferring to
get my info from her rather than whoever
this is the man doesn't break eye
contact with Amy Colonel Barksdale he
runs the place she says annoyed look
Barksdale she says you can berate me and
lecture me all you want when this mess
is over but right now I have a wounded
civilian here and as you can see several
entities trying to get into this room so
if you could actually do something
instead of sitting on your throne and
yelling at me that would be great I'm
impressed by her guts and wonder if
there's some sort of beef between the
two of them surely working in a place
like this could cause some stress and
tension
twing people as we wait I noticed a
small peephole in the door I go to it
and look out to the things they're still
looking for a way in but finding no
success honor if they can sense or
somehow see me through the door flip
them the bird yeah I'll do that
I'll do that middle finger defense I
can't help myself
I hold my middle finger up to one and
smiled and finally I get a blast of
high-pitched sounded responds you'll be
reprimanded for speaking to be in such a
way or stale says to Amy reprimand me
all you want
I'd like to survive this first cover
your ears Barksdale shouts walking away
Ford's the far end of the room stay put
until you hear back from me
thank you Amy says with fire in her
voice she then turns to me and says
better do what the man says yeah I'm not
gonna question I'm gonna cover my ears I
clap my hands of the meteors just in
time to protect my hearing from the
deafening blast I'm still bleeding and
the sudden movements cover my ears makes
me feel dizzy
deniz clumsily covers one of his ears
with his hand and one on with his
bandaged arm when I see the shape he's
in I get myself in check
compared to Dennis I'm in tip-top shape
I did that I took the shot that took off
hand I need to make all that means
something more burst of a loud explosive
noise start to ring out looking through
the people again I see the core of one
of the beasts explode it vanishes in a
puff of smoke and clear liquid looking
to my left I see Barksdale into shooting
stance at the far end of the room he's
firing through a small slit in the wall
he's using some high-powered weapon the
likes of which I've never seen I see a
slight movement of the gun kicks
accompanied by a flicker of white light
immediately another monsters downed its
tentacles flailing around aimlessly as
most of its core is torn through I
instantly feel gratitude and an immense
satisfaction in knowing they're being
picked off such a way I think we need to
sit down and rest
just one little bit of a breather I
slide down against the door and simply
wait listening to the occasional patter
of what I can assume is there blood on
the wall I don't know how much time
passes maybe five seconds maybe five
minutes and I don't care feels nice to
lay down even with the sensation of
blood rushing from my hurt shoulder when
the firing is over I barely even notice
it soon after Barksdale walks back over
to our side of the room they're all gone
barksdale says and I have Ria's filled
the hangar doors how did you kill them
like that I asked classified weapons
they're quite frankly you have no
business being near Amy gets to her feet
and returns to the panel on the wall
thanks how badly are the civilians heard
Barksdale asked one is in very bad shape
he's lost a hand on a lot of blood the
other is not too bad I see a laceration
on the back and that's about it okay
I'll have Strickland get a med kit mr.
Clint survived Amy asked sounding
hopeful yes and until you and your
friends showed up I thought we were the
only ones hanging tight she's on her way
with that said he retreats away to the
back of the room as if he can't stand to
be around us amy approaches me and looks
me over you're in good hands Strickland
will be able to fix you up if she a
doctor or something sort of she's also a
sight physicist but oddly enough she
spent time as a trauma nurse in the army
it's Strickland a friend of yours yeah
we've known each other for a while the
only women in a sea of overachieving men
you must be glad Strickland survived
focus on the good not the negative I am
we usually have lunch together and she's
helped me out with a few tight spots in
my career but then a few seconds the
door behind us open and woman appears
back further into the chamber she enters
the room with what looks like a small
suitcase she's dressed in a very basic
way and drab military get up complete
with a holstege sidearm my name is
Connie Strickland she says I can Pat you
guys up pretty well but it's going to
hurt she looks closely at Dennis looking
him over with precise care and attention
you're not in the best shape he responds
in a grunt shears that I can fix you up
but only temporarily you need intensive
care for what for that arm first things
first though Strickland pours a liquid
over his maimed arm and
start stitching she then wraps his arm
with three entire spools of gauze blood
shows through right away that's the best
I can do for now she tells him giving
him a sympathetic frown I could care
less that his mutters I'm a [ __ ] do
whatever you want is though it matters
Strickland then looks at me sit down and
let's see if we can get your shirt off
she says I sit down slowly and start on
bunting my shirt she has to help me slip
it off my shoulder but we manage how bad
is it I ask bad it's almost like a burn
but I've seen much worse your friend
here for example I might as well talk to
Strickland if only to distract from the
pain you're a scientist too
stricken rolled her eyes if she gathers
up a needle and some thread I was always
into fringe science
I started in labs with the eccentric
Russian scientists were being funded by
the u.s. to work on combining DNA types
I thought it became obsessed with
perfecting human physiology while it's
trauma nurse from the Army you were a
mad scientist then I get that a lot but
no not compared to the stuff we do here
I don't even want to know frankly I've
learned enough you sound like my mother
Strickland says she wants to make sure
I'm safe and cared for
she knows my job it's sort of dangerous
but of course I can't tell her any
details so she just worries any other
family I asked no she says that she
works on me I'm a workaholic no husband
no kids it's always been my job until
about a month ago and I loved it what
happened two month ago that's when the
teams were stumbled upon on to what they
thought was a big discovery Amy says
answering for Strickland
yes Strickland said that big discovery
resulted in 20 hour work days I've been
sleeping in my office for about a week
now when you guys ran in here I was
horrified those barrels outside I'm not
sure if you saw them but if you shot
them it could have been bad why I asked
the gray ones are filled with an
experimental fuel that's highly
flammable
the yellow ones contain liquid nitrogen
what just laying around well this area
is the safest in the building the most
secure well used to be anyway and take
this she says handing me four pills
painkillers they won't work immediately
but they'll dull the worse to what
you're feeling are these the best ideas
won't they make me dizzy or out of sorts
or something all I get in response is an
annoyed and determined look I'm gonna
hold off because if Dennis made it this
far in so much pain I can take a little
more I'll hold off I'm gonna hold off
I don't need it that bad really I say I
don't want to get lightheaded in case we
have to move fast I can handle it your
call Strickland says that she starts
working on me she slices the wound in
some sort of liquid it stings like crazy
and I gasp ouch owie
oh ow my wound my my interdimensional
wound yeah
that's not to complain with denison
ready to stab me yet I'm fine I hiss I
win so she dabbed in my eyes swollen
from where Marcus kicked me I grit my
teeth in pain and try to catch my breath
and it comes out of his hey Venus and
tries to speaking Strickling but his
words are slurred white light from the
ground and it says you think that caused
the power outage think that brought in
monsters out could be Strickland says
but your crew is far enough away from
the facility at least we thought you
were then it's chuckles in a way to make
some sound menacing nope wrong you
thought wrong so you and Barksdale is
the only survivors it seems that way
those that didn't disappear into thin
air were killed by those things circlin
says nodding to the secured door how
many were killed
I'm guessing 30 or so I'm not sure how
many were scheduled to come in today I'm
glad to see you where were you when it
happened Amy asks I was in the micro lab
on level 2 Strickland replies Park and
O'Brien were in there with me and they
just disappeared it looks like they were
being stretched distorted and then there
was a ball of white light and they were
gone the ball of light just annihilated
everything it touched would leave a
perfectly round hole I asked a light
bulb turning in my head we saw some of
those up the logging site yeah and I saw
a ball of white - that was probably the
same phenomenon
Amy looks at the ground like a child is
afraid to ask an adult for something
finally she asks where did they go we
don't know Strickland says it could be
an infinite number of different
dimensions or even some dimensions that
merge and mix together it could also be
a place that exists between dimensions
Barksdale calls it the void I'd call it
dead no we keep tabs on the heart rate
blood pressure and breathing of all the
rats and human test subjects wherever
they go for that time they're still very
much alive I winced through the rest of
Strickland's dancing that's fascinating
feeling the tug of my skin - thankfully
no more flowing blood circlin finally
says you're good to go she looks over
Dennis one more time he doesn't so much
as stir when he reach X her work she's
already having to remove the gauze on
his wrist as it's soaked through with
blood the wound looks like it's starting
to clog so that's good at least I stared
the floor as Strickland does what she
can will he make it I asked I'm not a
doctor not really but based on the bit I
know I'd say it's about 50/50 right now
so we have you and Barksdale been able
to contain all those creatures a masks
strickland appears shocked clearly not
the reaction amy was expecting contain
are you nuts
you not know what's happening Amy's eyes
widening fearful confusion what do you
mean what's happening other than the
initial experiment failure the anomalies
are becoming more numerous and further
from the source Strickland says the
casual humor in a voice has gone further
from the source are they everywhere now
from the location of the original
experiment the experiment caused the
first doorway to open but it set off a
chain reaction they're gaining momentum
along
emanating from the facility at these
pockets of exotic matter and negative
energy that are letting those things in
what the hell does that mean it means
Amy chunzhen that those doorways and
monsters are starting to appear all over
the facility maybe even the surface not
yet luckily but the doorways will start
appearing on the surface and it won't
stop there the anomalies reach could
extend infinitely as far as we know
those entities will appear on the
surface in other states other countries
holy [ __ ] I think you mean the world is
going to be overrun the horror of the
past VRS that made me ready to believe
anything but this is almost too much
unfortunately yes
my god Amy says stepping away is there
anything that we could do there is a
last resort circlin says her eyes
darting over Barksdale to back of the
room there's an emergency failsafe
switch what Amy says I never heard of
that where you weren't cleared for it
and that switch is a way to stop this
yes Strickland says seeming uneasy with
conversation what does switch do the
switches are eraser it destroys the
entire facility and terminates any
systems or experiments that are being
conducted it's also an emergency
shutdown for interdimensional travel it
puts an event horizon around the
facility what the hell is that that
black hole it's the perimeter of a black
hole the boundary inside which nothing
can escape not even life but there's two
problems we're hitting the switch so the
first problem is we'd all be killed
sucked into a black hole before we'd
have time to evacuate the second reason
is that Barksdale won't allow it
what why not he wants to allow those
things to plug the flood the surface
thousands millions will die Strickland
puts her hand up silencing Amy they both
peer over to the far side of the room
where Barksdale has his back turned I
know I know he says he doesn't care he
says he'll be happy to be rid of the
oversight so he can continue his work
the oversight Amy almost screams
regaining control of her voice when
Strickland gives her another look a
warning you mean our government I ask
he's aware this could disrupt even
topple our government and he doesn't
care
Barksdale is well he's off the range now
the gone rogue and he's armed his
comment makes me look towards the
handgun I brought in with me
I nearly forgotten in the last few
moments what Barksdale has his back
terms I've taken to my hands and slided
behind me just in time to as Barksdale
walks over from back of the room to our
side of the chamber he gives Strickland
a suspicious look before speaking door
of the two civilians going to survive he
asks then it's chuckles at this and I'm
revealed to see that his eyes are open
he gives a lazy thumbs up one is
stitched up and good to go but the other
here is in bad shape he needs immediate
medical attention
understood mark still says Amy it's
quite nice to see that you have survived
were there any others the aloof way this
[ __ ] is talking to us getting out of
my skin a guy named Marcus that works on
the first level from IT that's all I
know for sure
Marcus Pabst Scott where is he we're not
sure he was separated from us Oh
Barksdale replies clearly taken aback my
master and reply that's unfortunate
Barksdale seems to think about something
and then looks directly at me you're
with the logging crew aren't you remind
me how did you get in here again we were
searching for our crew ah makes sense
the clothes for the entrance shed are
tied to a primary source mark still says
and we lost primary power before the
experiment failed
cloaked I asked yes Strickland says the
shed you entered is usually not visible
to the naked eye depending on the power
sources that were damaged Barksdale
continues it could have also shut down
the locking systems before backups
kicked in everything is starting to make
sense down from the very start it seems
peculiar that we so easily been able to
walk into a place like this what caused
the experiment to fail your crew hit one
of our main power lines we aren't sure
exactly how but we know that's what did
it and trying to blame all this on me
the timing was unfortunate where's the
rest of our crew so it was
your crew Frank and Joe they're gone
gone done where they were annihilated by
antimatter pockets created during the
failure a bright ball of light
destroying them in the aftermath all
you'd see would be a round hole in the
ground our self says this like you
sharing yesterday's sports scores I let
my face crumble into my hands at
suspecting this all this time and they
were already dead behind me Dennis lets
out the beginning to sob in and he
mutters over and over so Amy asks what
do we do now now it's time to continue
our work Barksdale says calmly turning
away to the instruments near that wall
you're insane that is very clearly you
want to keep your little toys to
yourself I say my teeth clenched and
you're willing to unleash those monster
on the wall on the world to do it indeed
Barksdale says I want to continue my
work other researchers will eventually
discover what we have sure but I want it
to be me this is my laboratory these are
my experiments the work I've led here
will earn me my place in history and
quite frankly I don't need to explain it
to you upon the surface they'll struggle
to defend themselves since they won't
know what they're dealing with
I have the necessary weapons after a few
months who knows maybe I'll decide the
world is ready for me to help them and
we'll go from there
Strickland steps up directly beside me
and whispers in my ear I wouldn't push
him she says is usually very logical but
this whole thing has pushed him
somewhere else he's well off he turns us
back to us if he says this walking to
the far side of the chamber like we're
some kind of distraction Amy takes this
opportunity to whisper to us we need to
hit that switch it's the only option
what he's saying is murder treason
genocide she looks over to Strickland
for support trailing off but Strickland
looks to the ground clearly torn she
won't look anyone in the eye and makes
an effort not to look at Barksdale he
seems distracted with whatever
instruments you studying on the far side
of the room at this moment I realized my
body feels like a bomb went off inside
it
maybe those pain cows wouldn't have been
so
add strickland finally whispers a
response even if we decide that we want
to hit that switch Archdale won't allow
us you can figure something out right
maybe you guys could make a break for it
circling whispers where is this switch
located there's an elevator out in the
hangar take it to the basement that
switches at the low end of a long tunnel
you but strickland never finishes two
things happen to once she speaks her
mouth stopping in mid-sentence first a
loud booming noise rings out and then
the top of her head seems to explode amy
screams out in surprise and Dennis and I
jump back in shock and Strickland's body
collapses bohemian beside me behind her
fallen body arcs Dale is holding his
experimental rifle and now he's pointing
it at us holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
the music is way too calm for that my
god oh god that's not good
I wonder if Barksdale is even crazier
than Marcus he just shot a woman that
worked for him to keep her quiet surely
he won't have an issue with killing me
now Barksdale yells no more whispering
no secrets you three will stay in here
and get away from that door if anyone
whispers one more time I'll blow your
heads off my mind is racing to figure
out a way to get through the secured
door and into the hangar beyond that of
course there's a fail-safe switch in
solving Barksdale might not be the best
idea
make a distraction maybe I try my best
to be a good actor as I wobbled to my
feet of it I stop start forward again
and then wobble some more Amy is
apparently catching on because he's at
my side in a second she looks over at
Barksdale he's lost a lot of blood let
me check his wounds real quick after he
dared to talk to me like that he's went
through a lot he's clearly delusional
Dennis seems to not know quite know
what's going on but luckily Barksdale
isn't paying attention to him you can
check him back here you'll have 30
seconds to get away from that door or I
will I stretch out my acting skills and
actually stumble do Annie I make a show
of trying to get to my feet and still
stand still for a moment I'm okay I'm
okay I think I as quickly as I can
arrays my gun in fire I don't even take
aim I just fire in Marksville general
direction
Barksdale takes off running as my shot
misses why'd you run for cover to the
back of the room that's all we need Amy
fires a shot to keep them under cover as
we head for the door Amy pushes a button
and the door swings open our still will
be on us in a second so we dash out into
the hangar ready to defend ourselves I
can't believe he just killed Strickland
there must be something going on that is
driving people insane because Marcus and
Barksdale seem to be very off-color like
it seems like something is very wrong
all three of us run as fast as we can
get through the row of barrels right
away though arc steel gunfire separates
us I hear a shot hit nearby as I dive
down and realize that neither Dennis nor
Amy's with me I hear Amy cry out from
somewhere
the barrels peering around the barrels
closer to me I can see Dennis it's
crawling slowly on the floor two rows
away from me
Gina moves so slowly I can't imagine how
he's finding the strength to even do
that stop this nonsense I've got a good
mind to shoot the fuel and kill all of
you it's then that I realized that it's
not getting away from him these barrels
may be our death sentence well I mean
they're lucky they're a selfish thing or
a not selfish thing but I'm gonna tell
them to get away
I'm trying to be good here before I can
do anything a shot comes from the
isolation chamber it's immediately
followed by a pinging sound in a massive
wall of heat I feel the heat before I
feel the force of the explosion it
occurs several rolls ahead of me and I
can still feel the physical push of it I
hear Dennis scream and the clanging of
metal that's when another barrel
explodes and then another and I realized
I could run back and help or try to get
myself clear
I got a help I might not have enough
time to do either before the next round
of eruptions what the hell should I do
I've got to help them I've got to help
them I can't not help them my instinct
I'll help overcomes my instinct to
survive I don't help them now the
exploding barrels will leave Dennis and
Amy as good as dead I turn and start
heading their way but I'm not quick
enough another barrel blows up between
us and throws me back across the hangar
floor my face and arms screen with the
unimaginable pain of deep burns as I've
lifted from the ground and tossed
forward by the explosion I slowly
muscled myself up off the ground and try
to regain my footing my entire body
feels sore begging me to just stop when
I look back for Dennis and Amy the scene
is not promising neither them seems to
be able to move on their own
Dennis is lying flat on its face
unmoving Amy is about 20 feet away from
him she's wailing and pain and clutching
her leg behind them I can see Barksdale
looking for another shot through the
fire and evaporated liquid nitrogen I
fire off a single shot just to get him
to duck behind a barrel I look back and
find Dennis and Amy and see the fire
nearing the fuel barrels I can maybe
keep Barksdale pinned down long enough
to pick them up one by one and help them
walk to the elevators but more barrels
could blow at any moment not only have
time to save one of them Oh Oh No
I have to pick dennis's I'm not even
look at this from like I know Dennis I
know Amy standpoint like Dennis is the
one who has hurt more I don't even god
damn it
[ __ ] you chose to help Dennis first I
take a deep breath and sprint back out
in the open among the fire and heat
right away I start taking blind shots at
Barksdale he fires back only once and
the shot goes often growing flames
around me I take one more shot and then
reach down for Dennis he's basically
deadweight at this point he's almost too
heavy for me my wounded shoulder screams
in pain as I get him to his feet I
dragged him back narrowly avoiding the
fire and yet I tried shooting a bar sail
but keep trying to keep the gun in the
gun while carrying Dennis proves to be
too much our sail gets a single shot off
as we round the corner to where the
elevator waits
I said Dennis down and he's still
unresponsive drenched in sweat I reel
around and head back to get Amy I only
make it a single step before I see her I
open mouth my mouth call to her I'm an
explosion right beside her cuts me off
she shoved hard to the left from the
force of the explosion I've run the help
of Barksdale was firing at me again
I give Amy one last regretful look and
then rush back to the elevator in Dennis
my nerves are drenched in fear and
adrenaline when I reach out to press the
call button on the elevator it feels
like I'm watching someone else do it as
Dennis and I step inside the motors on
the elevator squeal like dying dogs
it's an old service elevator made of
wooden metal like something from a coal
mine as the elevator slides down the
light from the flames give away two
complete blackness and now it's just me
and Dennis once again good god the [ __ ]
is happening man this is [ __ ]
ridiculous this is [ __ ] insane
there's gotta be something with this
event that is driving people mad I lose
track of how long the elevator descends
it's hard to tell do the lack of
lighting but it must go down another 500
feet underground the elevator comes to a
stop of the shuttering clang and I waste
no time exiting a tunnel stretches out
with sparse white all lighting the way
most of the wall is made from raw earth
and rock but there are boards and
concrete slathered in areas used to
reinforce the tunnel
I see a warning sign posted on the wall
I want to read it but there's not much
time I got it I got to read the notice I
mean what's really gonna keep me up
I mean he's 500 feet up got a read at
least warning authorized personnel only
beyond this point trespassers will be
prosecuted to the full extent of the law
absolutely no exceptions well glad to
get out of that way now that everyone is
dead after only a few steps the pain in
my body intensifies how stupid was I'd
to turn down those painkillers I mean it
would have made me slow I look up and
when I see that the tunnel ceiling is
less than six inches over my head
claustrophobia freezes for a moment the
ceiling is not high and there's barely
enough room for Dennis and me to walk
side-by-side his eyes are half closed
and he looks on the verge of passing out
again it's okay I told we're almost done
a little further okay he shakes his head
and says I'm sorry Roger but I don't
think I can go any for further I lower
him to the floor as easily as I can and
let him rest I'll be back at home hoping
it's true the switch should be down here
somewhere
I give Dennis one last look and then
start down the tunnel and head to me I
look up and when I see that the tunnel
ceiling is less than six inches over my
head claustrophobia freezes me for a
moment
still it's much better than facing the
monsters above me why are things
repeating again
I wonder then walking through the
darkness where they came from if the
portal still open I keep walking into
the darkness and within five minutes the
glow of the red light from the elevator
is diminished someone's completely dark
hold the gun in one hand and reach out
to touch the wall with my other feeling
the gun in my palm anchors me to reality
to sanity I'm not in some boundless
abyss but still in the real world for a
little while longer and at least I
recognize that I'm marching to my end as
much as I wish I weren't it's not
surprising from the moment that I saw
those creatures could do to time and
space at least a part of me knew the
death was inevitable before I have time
to wonder what will happen I see a light
ahead it's nothing more than a speck of
blue light but in the darkness of the
tunnel it's like a lighthouse on a
stormy sea ice log forward my eyes
straining to focus on what little light
ahead
from somewhere ahead I start to hear
something that sounds like water it's
trickling like lightly like a leaky
faucet and behind that there's something
that sounds like wind a light breeze an
open field in a voice anywhere else the
sounds would have been Pleasant but here
in the blackness of the tunnel
they are menacing well that's not the
break character I keep shouting of the
darkness through this whole story hello
hellooo
my voice doesn't echo like it should in
this small space it's weirds me out even
more than the lack of response I [ __ ] my
head trying to concentrate and then I
realize that I can see the tunnel walls
now this is odd as I wasn't able to see
them a few seconds ago this is different
from the blue light at the end of the
tunnel it's then that I see this light
shimmering in the air looks like a foggy
mirror steamed over after a shower and
it's moving dancing in the air like some
abstract Firefly it's not menacing like
the creatures so that threat is no it's
peaceful serene i watch as the shimmer
branches out becomes two then three then
four they snake out in different
directions tracing the tunnel walls are
these shimmers with doors to another
dimension that Strickland was talking
about suddenly I'm surrounded by light
above and below me and I realized
there's no avoiding it the question is
how am I going to go through all right
I've had verse that's me I stick my head
through and feel a tingling sensation
almost Pleasant I reach out slowly my
hands stretching out to one of those
shimmers what I can only assume are some
kind of light they're hypnotizing so
much so that they don't realize that the
tunnel walls are vanishing I feel
something like wind and a brief
electrical pulse passed through me as
the lights take me there's been a very
gentle pushing sensation and I somehow
know that I'm being expelled I passed
through something maybe the lights
maybe the tunnel Walt I don't know but
the shimmering lights fade a bit still
dancing in the air but no longer large
and branching out and as my eyes adjust
I see right away that I'm no longer
standing in that dark tunnel far beneath
the hanger
I have no idea where I am I'm just
somewhere else and I'm terrified so are
these like the lights that took whoa
whoa are these like the lights that took
everyone else did I just get taken the
ground I land on looks like hot coals
they're dips in many cliffs breaking the
landscape ahead of me there's a wash of
orange and blue overhead in the sky that
makes no sense it's both beautiful and
terrifying at once a scattering of stars
hang overhead and they all seem to be
breathing and pulsing with the gentle
energy as if alive I can't tell if there
are clouds in the sky because everything
about it from the colors to the
trembling horizon life seems to be a
morphus everything is knitted together
living I stare a moment longer and can
square I feel the sky is leaving far off
to my right I think what looks to be a
plume of fire small again bright with no
source of fuel it looks as if the ground
itself is creating the flame several
more of these flames dot the landscape
further out the air is thick and muggy
then I realized something horrible I
don't know if what I'm breathing here
resembled air at all in a place like
this one of the impossible beauty but
also very stark horror my mind doesn't
know what to do a wave of nausea comes
over me and I think I might be sick I'm
not sure if it would be better to fight
it or give in the white light that
brought me here is nowhere to be found
if anyone else even here is there any
way to escape
well better continue my yelling I take a
deep breath whatever otherworldly gas is
filling this light and felt out as loud
as I can hello hello is anybody here I
hear a voice and response
it's faint distant I turned in here
coming from one of the massive crevasses
along the ground inside of that crack
about ten feet down a very pale man lies
on the ledge he's human but looks close
to death he's in the center of a very
large pool of blood and his left leg has
been twisted and torn in an unnatural
the walked the ledge he looks up and
sees me help me please the man says his
eyes are wide although everything about
him speaks of weakness he's close to
death or insanity or both who are you
I'm dr. Khanna he strains to get out I
work in the facility he's the one that
disappeared and never came back in the
experiment please help I want to know
more but it seems cruel to steal what
looks like his last breath just
answering my question I'd love to but I
don't know where the hell I am or how to
get back home the light it's the war way
might take you back to the facility
where did it go they come come and go
they'll be back now please help me I
desperately want to help but there's no
way I can reach him ledge is too far
away above the pool that's hired I don't
think I can get to you no that's not
what I meant he replies his eyes are on
the handgun that I almost forget that
I'm still holding I realized what he
wants and I shake my head I can't I said
I can't do that please easily those
things they have the others that came
here with me I got dropped along the way
they'll be back they'll be back and will
kill me that will be quicker and
lesbians
I can't I repeat please look at my damn
leg I'm dead anyway I'm about to refuse
them again want to hear an
all-too-familiar static sound out from
another crevasse behind him I hear
another of those shrill noises and then
watched one of the creatures
materializes up out of the neighborhood
grant neighboring crevasse two more come
out of that then a third then five then
ten soon I lose count is what was just a
few turns into a flood and I suddenly
understand the man's reasoning a bullet
would be a mercy
I checked the gun and see I only have
one round left I can use it on this guy
but I may need it for myself later from
beside me the man leans again my god he
says please not a decision that I take
lightly hood who knows how long he's
been here
they said that experiment looks like
what a month ago he chose to shoot the
man I look back to the Mandan winds I
know it's the right thing to do but my
finger resistance with the roar of
disgust I leveled the gun towards his
head turn my eyes away and then pull the
trigger your aim is true the man
crumples lifelessly to the ground and
that's when I see the shimmers wavering
to my right in the direction I
originally came from I look back to the
monsters and see that they have now
noticed me some of them begin floating
up the walls of crevice there are less
than ten feet separating us the shimmers
white light over the arm's reach
its movements reminding me of a fish in
an aquarium I reach out and feel myself
accepted by them again
I feel the sensation of wind and wave
for the feeling of being pushed out back
to the tunnel of this facility but it
doesn't come this time this time I feel
something else feel a tugging sensation
that seems to want to drag me in all
directions at once
the world goes dark I realize that I'm
somewhere else and it is not the
darkness of the tunnel this is the
darkness of a total void man this story
has taken us wild places and it's
[ __ ] amazing there's darkness around
me everywhere nothingness I feel nothing
under my feet nothing to my side I can't
touch or sense anything at all I you
know I don't even know which way is up
or down it's as though I am all that
exists and as I remain there I just hear
silence not even the sound of my
heartbeat the blackness is so deep that
I feel I can't distinguish my thoughts
and what is real I hear screaming but I
can't tell if it's someone else on my
mind screaming to fill this void and I'm
going to cry out because that's what I
do I hear my own shot in my head but it
doesn't seem to travel out in the abyss
it bounces in my head endlessly like an
echo down along ancient corridor
I assume this is the place that
Strickland referred to place between
dimensions this darkness could consume
me if it wanted to I try to will myself
out of it stab those shimmering lights
spit me out but it isn't happening at
this point my mind starts to hallucinate
or at least I think it does
are they visions my mind playing tricks
on me
I can't tell all I can do is watch I
shoot the logging site and Toni's like
still pinned under the dozer I feel a
pang of regret and I left him in such a
stream I feel myself talking to Dennis
and he looks distraught as I tell him
the Tony is gone then the scene
rearranges himself and I'm standing
between Dennis and Marcus's gun changes
again in the shape of Mark slides on the
ground still hell-bent on revenge
even after I let him live in my mind i'm
sobbing as i shoot off Dennis's hand
trying to convince myself who was the
only way to save him but he'll never
forgive me I tried to let out a scream
as Dennis and I watch Amy get blown
apart by the barrels explosions but
there's still no sound and just when I
feel like I can't take any more of this
I see the man in this strange world
begging for death
i watch as i take his life just before
those beasts reach him all of these
things are flooding my mind and it feels
like my brain is vomiting yet in the
midst of it all I see what's really
important this switch in my mind I I see
that glowing light in the tunnel the one
far ahead small and distance I focused
my mind on the tunnel and the image of
that flickering light with a mental
effort so strong that it's nearly a
physical motion I make myself envision
that little light in the tunnel as if it
were right there in front of me with
that I feel the wind again a light
breeze that seems to come from
everywhere and then with the relief that
I can only imagine feels like death I
move forward
[Music]
Jebus oh my god I'm ejected from the
void and suddenly standing in the tunnel
again I let out a wail of triumph that
turns into a bout of weeping the weeping
only intensifies when I see that light
of a head a flickering blue light
somewhere behind me I hear a crackling
noise I can only hope they haven't
reached Denis and it's too late to even
worry about that after coming this far
I'm not about to turn back I feel like I
can listen to get a better read on where
they are or I can just make a break for
it try to listen best then to just
sprint I try my best to listen to
attempting to figure out how far away
they are but the sound carries strangely
down here right now that static sounds
makes it seem like they're only about
thirty yards away knowing my time is
running out I run as fast as my aching
and Confused body will allow and it's
straight for the blue light as I run I
see a different light a white one for
Turing in my peripheral vision it's
another one of those shimmers that go to
other worlds it seems like they're
appearing and disappearing with more
frequency now Strickland was right these
things could reach the surface soon
unleashing more monsters this thought
makes me refocus on the blue light the
man-made light the switch the blue light
gets closer and as it does I can make
out a square shape around it
has to be in the familiar static screen
of the monsters is much close enough I
have to be quick
the grun the I grip the gun tightly
regretting my decision to use the last
bullet on the man in the other world
looks like all I'll be using this for is
a bludgeon
I've run ahead into the darkness my eyes
locked on the switch that I assume is
going to kill not only the creatures on
myself as well as I approach I see the
lever it's covered by a glass box that
I'll need a break the blue light is
directly beneath this highlighting a
series of tubes and wires that snake
into the inner portions of the device in
the middle is blackness not like a
darkly colored part of the machine but
just a hole in reality it looks like
some sort of illusion all the while I
can hear the static of the creatures
coming up dangerously close now I have
no idea how much time I have press
forward smash that glass I draw back the
stock if it gonna smash through the
glass box the houses deliver the glass
shattering like music to my ears I reach
out to the level my hand grasping it
without warning I feel immense pain
course through my body it feels like
fire racing down my back causing me to
fall to one need in agony there's only
one of them that I can see it blasts
horrible static noise at me as I ready
my gun with no bullets left I get ready
to use it as a club I try to strike the
monster gun that's the gun away wrapping
it into an S shape then follows up by
swinging and appendages at me this thing
of its touch forcing me back against the
side of the cavern MiFi striking the
wall hard my gel crunches on I feel
sharp pain encompass my head and the
creature is upon me its tentacles melt
into me and I scream I can't help it I
sound like a wild animal I can try to
keep sending it off or I can go for
broke I just focus on the lever
creatures be damned I'm going for the
lever I put all my strengths into my
legs the moment of the monster in front
of me draws back its eel-like arms grab
me I pivot backwards my back strikes the
machine sending agony rocketing through
my body I'm so thankful I broke the
glass before this moment before the
coming violence
I stretch out and grab the lever with
one last desperate scream that shreds my
voice I jam it down the tunnel is
suddenly filled with a flash of intense
darkness it expands from the switch
swallowing the matter around it at first
I'm sure this is the end of me
I expect the darkness to consume me
followed by death but then another
shimmer of dancing white light appears
next to me there are more of those
streams of life rips in space like the
ones that previously sent me to be other
ungodly world and the void with nothing
else to do but die I try to escape into
the shimmer on that stream of light
envelops me the expanding darkness of
the switch is gone and I feel a huge
push oh [ __ ] my own space my body feels
stretched collapsing like I'm falling in
all directions at once the world goes
white and then there are pinpoints of
stars everywhere one of them breezes in
directly by my right and I see something
that looks like a spiral galaxy
distorted in his folds to my right I see
an endless stretch of stars and gas
clouds forming some galactic
architecture but beyond the immeasurable
beauty I notice something I'm seeing the
same star patterns over and over they're
repeating like reflections in an endless
mirror for these are these different
versions of the same galaxies the same
realities to my left I see a calm blue
world and can barely make out trees
familiar Kentucky fries that I've been
around for the last few weeks to my
right I see a copy an orange world where
the trees well but something is strange
disturbing as i zoom by I'm not sure how
much control I have in this unusual
place but if I can direct myself it's
worth trying
is so weird me personally I'm drawn
towards the orange one because it's
something new I'm weirdly drawn towards
it I don't know why I try to focus my
mind on heading towards the orange world
not knowing what to expect my breath
escapes me for a moment everything is
dark and peaceful and nothing hurts yeah
I don't even know why like because
obviously the blue world is the familiar
world that I came from but this orange
world is like what's in there
why does it exist with breath back
inside my body I gasped and opened my
eyes I'm back back at the logging site
how I'm not sure did the shimmers react
with the explosion of the switch some
other accident I have no idea I sit up
right away and become instantly dizzy
Denis I say I have no reason to think
that he survived whatever happened in
the tunnel but there's some sort of
certainty that gets me to my feet I
wonder if I am somehow back in time
before we found facility but what
happens next makes me realize that can't
be true as I start walking forward I
feel a tremor in the ground someone off
in the distance I hear a metallic groan
in the buried facility it's being ripped
apart underground by the activation of
the switch
there's no way Barksdale and Marcus
survived good riddance I stumble a bit
and what I do I see the body on the
forest floor
Denis how is he here
did he get caught in those shimmers as
well I decided don't care and scramble
over to him Denis can you hear me yeah
he says the slightest twitch behind his
eyes for the moment that's good enough
for me to my left the rectangle of
partially destroyed trees in woodland a
pillar of smoke we can survive into the
air we've made it out of the facility
alive and that I suppose the most
important thing but something feels off
in a way I can't explain its then as I
look up and notice this guy that it
starts to sink in
there's something different about it
something not right that sky does not
belong here if the skies oranges and
blues stars pulse in and out as if alive
the colors of the sky seem to breathe
and if they're trying to inhale the tops
of the spruce trees I see those colors
all knitted together in living my
stomach rolls and arises up in my throat
what the hell I done but the end what
why oh oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh
my god what that's the end okay let's
talk about this tough it out was logical
because you don't want the painkillers
clouding your judgment
Janis has been with me the whole time I
can't leave him behind and also I didn't
know that I didn't know for a certainty
that it would kill one or the other I
don't know and I and 30% of people
killed the man or not many people and
then very very few people went to the
orange world and I don't know what that
means the choice between the blue in the
orange world they're like parallel
dimensions but one exists in the world
where that weird on fire hell landscape
world was the same sky the oranges and
blues that was the same sky the facility
was still ripped apart but what does
that mean did I have control over the
reality of what happened or is this a
parallel world where something has been
changed I don't know but that's the end
is there any sort of oh oh oh okay oh no
what did I do
you did yeah oh my god that was amazing
that was an amazing story that was this
an unbelievably amazing story I had the
time of my life it was like a book that
I couldn't put
it was so good and so weird and so
confusing what were the differences for
my choices they were so vast aah oh my
god there's [ __ ] incredible
like are there different endings to this
I have no idea I have no idea how many
endings there are let me look that up
actually I'm gonna look that up oh man I
can't I can't find anything on an
explicit walkthrough but I think this is
something that you guys just have to
experience for yourself there's a lot of
choices that need to be made in this
game and I don't know how much of a vast
impact it has on the actual ending or
what the ending fully means with the
ramifications of what I have done but I
don't know it's something that you guys
have to find out for yourself so if you
want to play this and you want to make
your own choices and you want to
experience your own story with probably
better choices that I made but my
choices were true to me try for yourself
a puddling in the description so thank
you everybody so much for joining me on
this adventure this was a ride this was
a wild ride and I loved every second of
it so thank you everybody so much for
watching it let me know what you think
of this down in the comments below
because there is so much to process and
I'm going to be thinking about this all
day long good either way thanks again
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
[Music]